all right Cindy
Cindy yeah it's been it's been years you
were one of the very first people I
interviewed down here in Skid Row
yep sure a couple years even down it's
good moving in attack since I was like
26.
and I'm 59.
wow
how is how has Skid Row changed over all
those years
well it hasn't it hasn't gotten any
better but it hasn't got any worse well
no I shouldn't say that
it's gotten better because
like they put more places up to live
they've built a lot of new things
there's different yeah more housing
um there's
like different kinds of people down here
now a lot of people giving out food and
clothing and stuff like that yeah feel
that not as much as before like that
they used to do that back in the day
remember they did that every day but now
it's like on the weekends you can
remember when there were no tents yeah
they were just on one street on town
that was the only place people and they
weren't even tents they were like
man-made yeah like makeshift little yeah
makes instructions now there's tents
everywhere yeah
yeah and the drugs have changed too yeah
you used to be a heroin addict I assume
now you're using fentanyl no no I don't
no I don't mess with fentanyl but I
guess that's the new drug out there yeah
but I think so you're you're you think
you're still using heroin well I'm not a
methadone program but I still do heroin
yeah but I just I I would bet your
heroine has fentanyl in it
I would bet your your heroin that you're
buying has something on it you know what
they've said that
but
I don't know I don't know I I don't know
how that drug is because I've never
tried it I've just like heard I've seen
it I've heard
it's like really really strong though I
think if it was in the heroine that you
would know it right away because it's
like really supposed to be real strong
and like you do just a little bit too
much you could die maybe maybe you're
your source is uh better than most
because I know a lot of people I know
have died from it oh yeah no but I think
if it
if it's in your heroin just a little bit
you get your body gets used to it and
you just
you can you can tolerate it and and you
wouldn't even know it was in there you
wouldn't even know
there's a lot of these drugs
yeah you just don't know
what is it that you think that's keeping
you here for all these decades
because I'm still in my addiction yeah
no kidding but
but there's something I think there's
probably something
deeper than just a drug addiction that's
making this life okay for you because
this is all I've known for all the years
I've been down here and it's like my
comfort zone
and and
I've always just felt safe and you adapt
yeah and and I've never I don't like
change I I'm not good with changing I
just don't know that if I was to go
somewhere else that I'd be all right
because I've never been
out of here is the outside world where
people are living normal lives going to
work paying rent doing things like that
paying taxes is that scary to you yeah
yeah
and I've never been anywhere else and I
I just I don't know how it is this is
all I've known
yeah you know and you have kids right
yeah they're grown
who raise your your children
my husband my ex-husband and my mom
what are your what does your family
think of your
decision to stay down here your whole
life they weren't happy about it
yeah they didn't like it at all
you still talk to them
not for a long time
my dad passed away in 2010 when I was in
prison
and
um my mom lives in Alhambra
and my brother but I haven't seen her
for a lot of years but she's okay though
what do you go through emotionally being
down here
is it depressing is it are you used to
it no I I'm unhappy because
I know that
I
these are better for myself
I just don't know how to go about
getting it
you know it's hard
what do you think
did something happen to you in your
childhood that maybe LED you
into this lifestyle no
you had a good childhood
yeah very good childhood I I don't know
I really can't say because I don't know
how did you first get a chance to use a
drug
how did drugs come into your life well a
boyfriend
it's always been because of a guy
introducing me to
a drug you know
because I didn't do just pick it up on
my own
you know
I guess yeah like
peer pressure
just wanting to do what you know I don't
know so I want to know what it is just
out of curiosity
but no one ever thought that you never
think that
I never thought heroin was going to take
over my whole life
and this was going to be the outcome
that I was going to come down here and
never leave
you know
you live on the street
and being a female down here makes it
even harder yeah it's hard it's not easy
you know you have to struggle how do you
I assume you get government support now
but there's people I have a lot of good
people in my life that help me
but like I don't I don't get a check or
anything I don't get money I just I just
try to take care of myself the best I
can
support no I don't I don't I get food
stamps that's all I get is
food stamps
and the rest is I just get my money
myself you know
how do you do that
like dating you still you're doing that
yeah
and that's with
just strangers that come through here no
just like the people I know that I've
been seeing for a lot of years
yeah that makes it safer yeah
and they like there's a lot I have a lot
of people that are that really care
about me and like you know they'll do
anything for me
do you think you'll be down here the
rest of your life
I I I don't know but I hope not
I don't want to
maybe that door will open one day
for decades down here
you've seen a lot of people get killed
not a well not a lot but
if you're paying attention you see it
happens every day it happens yeah it
happens a lot I hear about people
getting thrown out of
Windows yeah but or jumping out of
Windows
but I've never really seen anybody get
killed yeah what's interesting about
skid row now because everyone's in a
tent when you're inside a tent you don't
see what's going on outside the tent
yeah and people also don't see what's
going on inside the town yeah so you
drive through skid row and it's just a
bunch of people camping yeah but if you
knew what was going on inside those
tents that's probably why I was always
in in my tent so that's probably why I
don't because I don't really be I go to
the store take him for his walks but I
don't really be hanging out in the
street but it's gotten a lot quieter
like there's not a lot of people hanging
out on the streets
like there was before we got housing now
yeah it's like the streets are
getting less and less people on them you
know
if that's a real solution to the problem
but it it makes good relical
the less they're trying you know
you know you're trying yeah
I think it's just a Band-Aid
what's your biggest regret in your life
starting you
starting doing drugs I didn't know about
like heroin
you know that was my biggest downfall
where were you planning on doing with
your life when you were young
did you have any goals
um
I thought I was gonna
have my own flowers
store flower shop yeah I thought I was
gonna own a flower shop
be a flourished
and Cindy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
[Music]
the most important lesson
not to let people persuade you
into doing things that you don't know
you know
probably that
all right Cindy thank you so much for
sharing your story okay great seeing you
again okay thank you good luck with
everything